diomandé squeeze on se retrouve
aujourd'hui pour une idée du prix
spécial ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas
vu l'autre de bêtises et et vous êtes
vraiment nombreux as vraiment envoyé des
messages pour dire moi les femmes
baptisé tout et podcaster petit montage
et tout ça peut être marrant et c'est
vrai que ça peut être marrant en effet
donc mais j'ai pris une petite heure et
demie soir pour vous faire le bêtisier
de la vidéo art in harlem à harlem
cheikh pardon avec mon frère donc avec
le déguisement le beat de grieg gaillac
les ailes et d'où elle ça peut faire je
peux je pensais que ça pouvait être un
peu folle et puis voilà bah j'ai lu vos
messages et tout et c'est souvent
revenus ces derniers mois les fait
débiter fait des bêtises et ce que je
comprends je n'avais fait par exemple
dont j'aime call of
et j'en ai d'un geek bref c'est parti
vous me dîtes si vous aimez si vous
voulez que j'en fasse encore ou pas et
je voulais si le bêtisier tu as tout le
monde peas et bonne soirée
on conçoit ses pairs quand tu dis ça
turrian juste fixement exact il est dit
que ça commence un peu tu commence
doucement et accèlèrent au fur et à
mesure où kaka this party 3 2 1
pas mal est fait
bah pas rire du tout c'est super dur sur
une plage était le trouve pas qu'il fait
chaud tu réponds comme à sept ans et
demi tu la sors ça s'agite rostand
j'avais l'impression que mon
à givet un best of de cette scène mais
je veux pas à ses origines beaucoup
tourné deux mecs comme ça moi je vais
sur tes oreilles un bon package avec les
tribus de ces bans broadway
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
allez je vais me saouler d'aprimo n'est
content qu'il avait le moral
mais mon gars c'est quoi ce truc on met
trop la mecque j'apprends à sale [ __ ]
made et dans deux minutes mon père livré
à destination je répète en ouais pas
dire tout boosté tout message pouvant
bouger la moindre partie de ton corps
quoi bon ami canard voilà c'est pourquoi
il se cale trop alors attends merde je
préfère évoquer ce n'est pas à la fois
que je répète aux moeurs l'annulation
focus média la focus était déjà plein je
répète oui oui je m'appelle aurait
souhaité un montant plus que jamais
lancé attend maintenant tu vraiment le
dire mais on s'est rompue ça reste un
peu trop basse a fait trembler la seule
fois qu'on regarde donc on met la vidéo
on aime tous que la partie du mauvais
temps qui avait mis croire ça c'est je
pense ce n'est en fait on ne voit pas où
je me décale genre bon voit à peine en
fait assez c'est bon c'est bon la beauté
elle a à cet effet
m
ces bons chiffres mais je vais mais
cette tête une loi
[Musique]
m